ann heyche in a fight for her life as
new details emerge about her fiery crash
welcome everyone to entertainment
tonight you know we're also learning
more about anne state before the crash
lauren zema is on site where every
second is critical in ann's recovery
e.t has learned that the actress was
first treated at the ucla medical center
nearby to the crash then moved here to
the grossman burn center because her
injuries are much worse than we were
originally told
[Applause]
she has two very significant serious
life-threatening injuries
anne's rep tells e.t the actress is in a
coma in extreme critical condition and
has burns requiring surgical
intervention
we spoke today to dr michael cooper who
thinks anne is battling severe burns and
smoke in her lungs based on the videos
that i've seen the level of filling
smoke she would have sustained extensive
deep third degree burns
e.t has confirmed that anne is under
investigation for misdemeanor dui and
hit and run and the lapd also tells us
that a warrant was obtained for a blood
draw on ann on friday we're also
learning more about the seemingly random
encounter that ann had just moments
before crashing her car into a home she
wasn't
acting erratic or anything as such today
i spoke to hair salon owner richard
glass who told me the actress bought a
bright red wig from him just moments
before the accident she asked if she
could purchase a blue one that was also
on the counter i said no it's already
commissioned for another another
customer sorry no word on why ann bought
the wig though she has been busy with
new acting roles she recently starred in
the vanished for netflix and plays a
lawyer on the own show all rise and you
don't think that's going to get left out
of court the actress also appears in the
weekend's upcoming hbo series the idol
but the 53 year old who famously dated
ellen degeneres for three years has also
been through a lot including a traumatic
childhood i believe i was sexually
abused by my father from the time i was
a very young girl
actually before i could speak
up until the time i was 12.
anne is a mom of two she shares her son
homer with real estate agent coley
lafoon and another atlas with actor
james tupper ann's other ex actor thomas
jane released a statement saying quote
my heart goes out to anne and her two
sons
[Music]